what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and I'm back at it again to talk
about the latest craziest developments
in the demon slayers story this chapter
was crazy good and just as predicted the
mangaka had plenty more tricks up her
sleeves the twists and turns keep coming
every chapter and I love it if you enjoy
these weekly chapter reviews and want to
keep them coming make sure to smash that
like button to let me know and share
this video with a friend if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future demon slayer videos remember
that you can catch all these reviews
before they even come out on youtube by
following anime up or audio on spotify
itunes for wherever you listen to
podcasts you can find the links in the
description I want to also give a huge
thank you to our glorious patrons over
on patreon who helped us survive YouTube
issues and who make videos like this one
possible more about our glorious anime
up for patrons at the end of this video
for now you should know that there will
be manga spoilers we are talking about
the latest chapter chapter 193 after all
you've been warned now if I further ado
let's jump into it on the cover of this
Weekly Shonen Jump issue art Angela and
a Zuko Demon Slayer deserves to be the
focus of this week because of this epic
battle for sure I even hope that Nessa
Co being on the cover was a hint that
she'll show up in this chapter but alas
she did not get nevertheless this cover
is a reminder that she is coming and
that we'll probably see her sooner
rather than later we started a chapter
with moose on who's getting all
philosophical it's very interesting
actually we're getting access to his
thoughts and worries as if he was a main
character rather than the monster of the
series it is clear that the mangaka
wants to humanize everyone as much as
possible in this series even the main
monstrous antagonist who's still
suffering from PTSD because of his
encounter with your Ichi
anyways muslins thinking about living
creatures and how on the threshold of
death they become much stronger than
before moose on knows that some people
can open the door to a new sense or
power that they didn't need in an
ordinary life they rise to the occasion
and those who can't open that door die
we've probably all heard of those
stories where mothers suddenly get
strong enough to lift a car in order to
rescue their babies when pushed into a
desperate corner
humans can do things that wouldn't
ordinarily be possible Tundra is one of
those people that can open the door
rather than folding when times get tough
like the fire pillar that was mentioned
in the last chapter Tundra fights and is
able to unlock new powers and access
more energy than you'd expect
on a sidenote it's nice that we got some
colored pages for this chapter colored
pages always enhance the already
existing height the words final battle
are included seemingly confirming that
this is the final battle against music
and that unlike some fans speculated
Mouzon will not run away it seems pretty
clear that he will be defeated without
escaping sooner rather than later for
now Mouzon goes on to think about how
ton judo can now turn his blade red
without relying on his sister's power
and how even the pillars can turn their
blades red they can all open the door
that he's been talking about but they
still can't keep up with him in his view
and that includes Tanja though he says
that after some time Tundra will not be
able to keep up with his moves we even
get an interesting comparison here
between tundra and yuri cheese remember
that Mulan has fought them both and he
tells us that compared to your Ichi
dangerous strikes are not even close to
the same level to an extent we knew this
but Musa makes it clear that Tundra is
not nearly as powerful right now as your
ichi was so how can he hope to win well
as I mentioned last time it will
probably be a team effort since Demon
Slayer tends to be all about team
efforts despite how sure of himself
Mulan feels time judo keeps fighting he
keeps using the dance of the fire God
forms and we even see what appears to be
the shape of a fiery dragon this is
pretty hype since it reminds me of
when's I need to used his lightning
dragon move that's a really exciting
parallel for me and I'd love to see them
use some combine dragon moves at some
point for now tundra is halfway through
the twelve forms he's struggling he
stuck to packing and it's not
comfortable he has to maintain a
ridiculously fast speed that is pushing
his lungs limbs and heart past their
limits he's feeling like this already
and then we are told that there's one
hour left until sunrise
if he actually kept thinking about how
much time is left he'd be too worried
and he wouldn't be able to concentrate
that's why he tells himself to not think
of anything beyond this one second it's
similar no matter what you do I ran a
half marathon for the first time last
year and thinking about the 21
kilometers ahead of you is not gonna
help you last until the end you have to
just focus on the next step and
eventually if you keep doing that you'll
finish do the best you can in this
moment and trust that the rest will take
care of itself
tundra is doing exactly this it doesn't
look good since the sword hands and feet
are slowing down but still he decides
that he'll focus on one second at a time
and repeat that for every second until
sunrise Wow - once said if you are
depressed you are living in the past if
you are anxious you are living in the
future if you are at peace you are
living in the present Tundras only hope
of winning is the safe focus on the
present if he loses a sense of peace aka
his cool he'll make a mistake and moves
on will finish him off if we humans just
focus on the present take things one
step at a time
and don't get too ahead of ourselves we
can even achieve seemingly impossible
feats we jump to moves on who notices
that Tundras technique is deteriorating
and he believes that his blade will
revert from red to black soon then we
get a nice meta moment where moves on
thinks that there's no way you could
make it that easy he means it's not easy
for someone to perfectly imitate your
cheese forms and skills but we can also
read it as referring to the mangaka at
the end of the last chapter things seem
pretty straightforward times si yo
Deecee performed the forms and he
corrected his own flaws and it seemed
like he was gonna perform the forms
flawlessly until sunrise without getting
tired and the big bad moves on would be
defeated however there was no way the
monk akka could make it that easy we
need some complications
the young ton judo can't just suddenly
become the most powerful demon sailor in
history by seeing some memories suddenly
it starts to seem like moves on has the
upper hand Tundra coughs up some blood
but he manages to avoid a deadly
tentacle moves on is shocked by this
even though Tundra is slow as ever and
his movements have no precision and he's
a human who should be hindered by
fatigue the harder he moves moves on
can't hit him he wonders why he can't
kill one exhausted
worn out human then Mouzon realizes
what's happening and this is quite the
twist
Mulan's been slowing down too that's why
he can't deliver a finishing blow on
Tangier oh and it appears that Tommy oh
the demon yo Deecee saved is the reason
that moves on keep slowing down he goes
inside himself and tries to question
Tommy off but of course she's not gonna
cooperate she tells him that she's not
telling him anything she reminds me of
Shinobu here those two make a great team
moves on decides to just read the
memories of her cells he sees Shinobu in
the memories and she talks about the
drug that returns a demon to being human
however if it doesn't work another
poison will take effect it's an aging
drug that could Age moves on 50 years a
minute once it gets broken down moves on
finally realizes that he's been aging
he's been losing strength while his body
is trying to halt the aging process that
accounts for the struggle he had with
the pillars and the others I'm extremely
glad we got this part I don't know about
you but I've been wondering how Mouzon
was struggling to quickly kill demon
Slayers before they even turned their
blades red and now it finally makes
sense he was struggling because of the
aging so he's not as strong now as he
was against you at Ichi and that's
primarily thanks to Tommy ol ancient oh
boo
I love the fact that Shinobu had
something to do with this she was an
awesome character and it sucked to see
her die
but it's amazing to know that she played
an important part in creating a drug
that is helping to defeat the demon king
of pop right now this isn't a case of
the protagonist getting ridiculously
strong out of nowhere and defeating a
ridiculously opie villain by themselves
this is a case of so many different
people's efforts that are coming
together and giving time to a fighting
chance even though he's nowhere close to
your each's level it's really great
stuff and great writing on the mangakas
part moves on does some quick demon math
and he figures out that his ages get
this over 9000 I'd like to believe that
that number was intentional and I love
it
very cool got a guess on very cool then
Musa mentioned something that actually
crossed my mind - he said he should have
figured out what was going on sooner
because the colour wasn't returning to
his hair it stayed white I had
just assumed that this was his true aka
final form but I guess the white hair is
a sign that his vitality has returned
it's also interesting that aging affects
demons I assumed that demons wouldn't
really be affected by aging and they
could just live forever and stay young
but it seems like even they can be
affected by aging and they can get
slowed down especially when we're
talking thousands of years we see a crow
proclaim that there is 59 minutes before
dawn so we're making progress here for
the first time there's less than an hour
left but I'm not gonna lie though 59
minute still seems like a long way off
those 59 minutes could be spread out in
many many more chapters we get some more
shots of tundra dancing and at the same
time fighting effectively against Mulan
Mulan is clearly frustrated as he hits a
mirage while the real Tundra continues
to dodge and land some seriously good
slashes including slashes that
temporarily take off Milan's arm he
continues to put pressure on moves on
until he's unleashed all 12 forms they
all connected and tundra is determined
to use the forms faster and more
accurately he's ready to repeat the
twelve forms until the Sun rises he's
determined like last time to win and
like last time he appears side the upper
hand at the end of the chapter in one
translation at the end of the chapter
it's written let it burn your heart a
clear nod to Dan Goku loving the
recurring references to a tango Kuya
Ricci and Tom I owe this chapter even
included Shinobu which was a real treat
she's definitely an underrated character
my view her amazing poisons and her
skill for strategizing should not be
overlooked this chapter was a bit of a
roller coaster we got to a point where
it seemed like Hunter was in trouble for
a second but he turned out to be fine
time to dodge Milan's lethal blows and
he feels like he can now keep going
until dawn right when things did seem
hopeless for ton zero that's when we
figured out why Mouzon hasn't been
wrecking everyone this whole time it's
because he's been aging rapidly because
of the poison he absorbed from Tamayo
thus he was struggling with the pillars
even before their swords turned red
because of the poison and tundra is able
to keep from being hit not because he's
anywhere close to your age is
but because moves on keeps getting
weaker and weaker it seems more and more
of his energy needs to go to battling
the aging process so that his movement
speed and possibly strength and
regeneration speed are going down I
still think that Tundra is a strong it's
living demon say right now but the
mangaka is making it clear that one of
the reasons he's doing so good against
Mouzon is because moves on is getting
weaker and slower as time goes on it's
definitely an interesting approach that
the manga is taking here sometimes I'm
showing you have villas defeated when
they're at their strongest by one
character who got a massive upgrade for
example think about the fight against
Super Saiyan Goku who went out of his
way to let Frieza achieve his full power
so that Goku could fight and beat Frieza
at his best this is often not the way
that the demon Serra mangaka does things
we never got to see upper moon to dolmas
full power because he was poisoned by
Shinobu we never got to see upper moon
three offices full power after his head
regenerated because he self destructed
when he regained his memories so it's
clear that unlike some other mangaka
gotaga son is totally cool with
defeating villains when they're not at
their strongest thus the fact that moves
on has been weakened by Tommy Owen
Shinobu isn't weird it isn't weird for
Demon Slayer that we don't get to see
one character get soapy that he defeats
the opie demon opponent at his best
Demon Slayer has always been about
teamwork teamwork and helping each other
evens the odds and lets humans make up
for their weaknesses against the usually
much more powerful opie demons even your
Ichi the strongest human and character
in the entire series couldn't kill the
demon king of Pop on his own thus it
makes sense that it took a lot of help
from others for Tundra to get this far
and it's gonna take more help from
others including from nesic oh I bet for
him to finish off moves on once and for
all
in the end moves on will lose and I will
no doubt be the result of a team effort
in my view it seems pretty clear that
that is the way this fight is going to
end
I appreciate this formula that gota get
son uses it never feels cheap to me or
unbelievable it's like that one mutant
quote if I have seen further than others
it is by standing upon the shoulders of
giants tundra will only get
further than others in defeating Mouzon
because he stood on the shoulders of a
ka got help from others like your ichi
angle cool Tamayo
and many others let me know what you
think is gonna happen next it's unlikely
that ton zero we'll just keep wrecking a
helpless moves on since we know that
gotta get son likes emotional roller
coasters we're probably going to see
many more reverse uno cards played
before this is over
perhaps Milan's body will even get over
to poison somehow I'm guessing that he
will somehow turn the tables on time job
before Naza ko shows up to help I just
hope that he doesn't become stronger by
absorbing Natsu ko that might make for
an intense and interesting story but I
can't see us losing Nezzer ko the fans
including me loved her too much for that
to happen but anyways that's it for this
one as always thank you so much for
watching and if you enjoyed this video
please smash that like button and share
this video with a friend that really
helps the channel and in doing so helps
me to keep producing more videos like
this one if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell or else you will miss
future demon slayer chapter reviews
remember that you can catch all of these
reviews before they even come out on
youtube by following anime up or audio
on spotify itunes or wherever you listen
to podcasts you can find the links in
the description a special thank you goes
to our patrons over on patreon who help
us survive youtube issues and who helped
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost I want to thank our the one
tier patrons the ones who stay on top
all clans Stephen and Radha
al Ola attempt the world Steelers the
school bus and Tyson Kirino and I can't
forget our pro hero to your patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings eldress $30 beat
Anatoly Cassatt Suki alpha do angel Cruz
team Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor Taku Timothy
Edward Vargas Jeanne d'Arc Joel Stanton
and JCCC waka thank you all so much if
you enjoy our work you can support more
of it by going over to
patreon.com/scishow and Meowth drawer
and becoming a patron today for as
little as $1 if you do so you
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course dank memes so
check out patreon accomplished and may
uproar link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you will get the
same great benefits thanks for
everything and until next time see us
space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]